Alex here with a gamespot news update
did you ever wonder why digital games on
consoles stay more expensive than their
physical counterparts Ubisoft recently
shed a little light on this subject
during a post earnings conference call
question and answer session Ubisoft was
asked about the disparity Ubisoft CEO is
gman said digital is more reactive than
what we put in stores but at the same
time it doesn't react as fast on
consoles than it does on PC where we can
say is that when games are older than
one year digital is a lot more dynamic
on console because there are less units
and stores it's a new business a new
trend and we think all this will get
more in line with time but for sure at
the moment you see all sorts of prices
depending on who is doing a promotion
for that specific week an example of
this pricing is far cry 4 the first
person shooter still sells with 60 bucks
on PSN even though you can pick it up on
amazon for twenty four dollars on any
given day piemonte also pointed to one
other factor that needs to be taken into
account which is how many copies of a
particular game are left on store
shelves you said one thing to consider
is related to stocks we have stock in
stores we tend to make sure we decrease
the quantity of units and stores before
going digital with lower prices digital
or physical the debate still rages on
let us know what you think in the
comments and for more news keep an eye
on gamespot com
you